you mentioned your your foray into into
comic book movies we're still living
through these comic book movies and I'm
wondering if you had advice for a
hypothetical future new Scott Summers
what the hell should be yeah I guess the
biggest challenge was that was never the
audience and other actors never being
able to see your eyes it was like it
definitely was a handicap in like
bringing bringing a persona to the
character and an energy to the character
that to a character who also is very by
nature very by the books and very you
know have a boy scout and do the right
thing you know and it's a is a foil to
to Wolverines character who's like more
fly by the seat of his pants you know
more unpredictable and and aggressive so
I mean I would just say you know just
just lean into it and own it and and and
carve out your own thing like that you
know the fans in the books are gonna
tell you like it needs to be this like
you know to find your a new way to make
it interesting you know because it is it
is tough to like you know get something
interesting and cool and different
across when you don't no one ever sees
your eyes which is obviously the main
part of character